Wow James Wan is on a roll are you
kidding me with this guy he's triggered
like two movies in one month I think he
woke up one day and he was like you know
I'm going to take over Hollywood that's
what I'm gonna do I say James Wong you
do that and cancel that Ninja Turtles
movie good
insidious chapter 2 so insidious chapter
2 you wouldn't know it from the title
spoiler alert is chapter 2 of insidious
I guess they're the insidious movies by
chapter now and this is chapter 2
ultimately an insidious one night owl
went into the spectral realm like Raziel
from legacy of Canaan [ __ ] to go get his
kid he got his kid back but something
else came back and now these people in
this movie have to deal with that [ __ ] I
mean I heard about that I was like
that's basic sequel movie [ __ ] all
right cool ultimately though I did enjoy
this movie this movie does have its fair
share of scares and [ __ ] like that you
know it's insidious - if it didn't you'd
think it was weird like they're gonna
have James Earl Jones in front of a
fireplace I like good morning today
we're going to talk about my days as
dull feet oh that would be weird so they
gotta have their horror movie [ __ ] cuz
it has to be insidious too however the
movie doesn't really rely on that I
didn't find insidious - overwhelmingly
scary I just found it interesting which
should suck ass I should walk out of in
cities to being like that wasn't as
scary as it should have been that's
[ __ ] oh really when I was watching
it I was like okay what are they gonna
do they need to solve this puzzle
they're following the breadcrumbs in the
paper trail though the spectral paper
trail there's a spectral prey their
spectral paper trail that's hard to say
you want to see the next step you're
like solve that puzzle so we can get to
phase twos we can get to Phase three I'm
interested in that [ __ ] it's more of an
interesting movie the whole time I was
like so it's like Scoob like we're gonna
have to solve the mystery of the Boy
George killer and here we are some of
the stuff is a bit obvious you're like I
know what's happening there's one part
in the movie in particular it was really
cool I was like this is smart [ __ ] this
is awesome it does detract from the
scary aspect and element of the movie
which again should suck ass for a movie
like insidious but I'm just saying it
really intrigued me it's like the
coolest parts of the movie were the
parts that made the movie less scary
Darth Maul's not in the movie anymore
that's right you know that little Darth
Maul imp not in this movie it had some
awkward humor in it - I was like James
Wan you're trying to be funny
Jun go all Michael Bay honest man you
know that awkward humor where the
directors like hey this will be funny
let's let's do that trust me it'll look
good it'll be funny and it's just kind
of out of place for where the movie is
at that moment that happens a few times
in this movie you're just like as kind
of awkward all and although I really did
enjoy this movie couple of creepy
moments not real
overwhelmingly scary movie but it was
intriguing and it was interesting fans
of the first one who want a horror movie
again they're gonna be pissed off I
think James Wan hoard all of his horror
movie ISM this into the conjuring he was
like I got no more left I let's make
insidious too and make it just
interesting that'll piss some people off
it'll intrigue others I myself was
interested in the movie I will say
insidious chapter 2 is a good time no
alcohol required insidious chapter 2 is
a good chapter 2 of the insidious
trilogy I imagine it's going to be the
insidious trilogy and you're going to
have three solid ish movies and then
you're going to have four shitty ones
and then after that seventh movie or
whatever they're going to reboot it and
we're going to start all over again when
insidious movies start coming out in
January you know the end is not right so
insidious chapter two have you seen it
what did you think about it you like
insidious one or you like I didn't like
one I'm not gonna watch two whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more